Sadie: Sometimes I just feel like nothing I do matters. Like I'm not special.
We only got one retweet today. From your mom. Sad.
We were just wondering if maybe you could give our blog a shout out?
Toby: A shout out from me would be a little off-brand.
I have 15,000 followers.
You know what that means, with a community like this?
McKayla: More to the left, his heart's more to the left.
You're just hitting bone, dude!
Sadie: I'm trying!
["Always Forever" by Cults plays]
[McKayla?:] Rosedale High is trending!
McKayla: I really hope nothing bad happened to him.
Sadie: It's like, poof! He vanished, right?
McKayla: Anybody could be next. Even you.
Sadie: You can find more information on our Tragedy Girls Twitter page.
McKayla: Your brains, my charisma... We could do anything.
Reporter: Quick sound bite from the Tragedy Girls.
McKayla: OMG.
Sadie: Can you [unintelligible]
Reporter: Are you afraid that the killer will target you because of your infamous blog?
McKayla: We will not take any more shit from this serial killer.
I'm so scared right now.
We look amazing.
[?:] Jeez. McKayla?
McKayla: Shit!
Sadie: Dammit, McKay!
McKayla: I'm sorry!
Sadie: Stay in character.
Teacher: Phones off!
Sadie: But it's a matter of life and death.
Big Al: You bitches are crazy!
[McKayla, Sadie and Lowell laugh hysterically]
McKayla: We used to be the same, you and me.
Do you remember our first time?
Reporter: I just want to know, what's next for the Tragedy Girls?
[Janitor obliviously whistles]
Jordan: What happened there?
McKayla: Nothing.
Jordan: Is that blood?
McKayla: Heavy flow day.
Jordan: I don't know if- that's not how that works, right?
[Subtitles end here]